that does not negate the fact
that the current era we're in
is not
looking for a new voice
do you feel movies today are less
entertaining than they used to be
yes
that's absolutely um
uh
reason why is because i think we're in a
fallow period
um for movie making and i think people
are afraid of taking risks and
i think um
that
a lot of movies are cookie cutter and
because of the way that the business is
structured right now um it's a it's it's
not allowing for um a lot of
new talent to emerge and
and receive the kind of attention that
it should
um i think that um
there's periods where the pendulum
swings on that
um
and
that
the opposite is the case
but right now we're in one of those
fallow periods and hopefully it will
swing in the other direction
um in the in the 90s we had a very
great night amazing era i think it
lasted a little bit into the odds but
after that
it just
you know went back to to
to um
to you know mostly studio fair i have
nothing against studio films by the way
i think they're fine um and they're fun
but you need to have other stuff too um
and we don't have enough of the other
stuff um 70s we had a lot of that other
stuff
and
and now it's just another one of those
periods where we just don't have a lot
of that other stuff
why do you think that is
well it's um it's just kind of the way
um
the business is
has been structured um and um
it's it's
it's kind of like
we had a new influx of um
of
of people um in to the system um in the
90s from you know
new kinds of producers new kinds of
um
executives so that there's
there is a legitimacy that um
that independent filmmaking received in
which it was actually
actually
was
if not
prestige it
it was given consideration as far as
being
having money making possibilities
and some of those films did make money
um
but
but now um the party is over um
the the the movies that they that they
acquire at places like can and sundance
are already set up
you know it's like you don't you don't
get in there
on a lark like you used to you're not
you're not you can't be a wes anderson
you can't be a
kevin smith
out of the blue you can't be you know
you you're you know you're already
you're already um
you're already fully funded and backed
by
um some kind of um
corporate arm
that allows you those kind of
opportunities
and
that's just the case
once again i have no judgment over those
things it's just just the way it is
um
i'm hoping that because of the streaming
territory that we're in now
that sort of allows a little more
wriggle room
for that
for that to see the light of day in
which there can be
new kind of
new kind of talent um
um taking advantage of those sources but
i
i don't see where the evidence is of it
yet
you know
um hopefully there will be
do you think filmmakers are forcing a
message in today's films
um i don't
think that um
i don't think that there's
okay um that's a complicated question
um and i'm going to like answer it like
this um
i
enjoy watching
martin scorsese movies
um and
i
really enjoyed watching the irishman
because i thought it was a great
um
great
historical um
um
road map and
it had a a greater message about the the
the american story
and um
i am so
glad that that someone like that even
though he has to fight for it
given his status as a filmmaker
that someone like that has the luxury to
to um to have that kind of message that
he can put forth in the in his films
um
but not everybody has that luxury
and
not everybody has that kind of
opportunity
and certainly um
the the
the the new martin scorsese the young
martin scorsese the female martin
scorsese the black martin scorsese the
asian martin scorsese
aren't getting that opportunity
and um
because they all have
statements that they want to make about
america
[Laughter]
and
um
and those aren't those aren't salable
in in today's market
you know
those aren't
those aren't things that people want to
um
to necessarily
finance and it is what it is now i'm not
saying you know finances are bad or
or or um
or studios are bad and they're they're
they're the boogeyman or anything like
that
i think that's really
a
a horrible attitude to possess
[Music]
i think there's a lot of filmmakers that
are proponents of a sort of victim-like
stance
but that does not negate the fact
that the current era we're in
is not
looking for a new voice
vigorously
so the martin scorsese that was able to
tell the irishman
how different was that person that told
the story of taxi driver traffic i i
really don't think um um
much of a difference i mean i think it's
the same spirit
you know i think he's a he's a he's an
incredible filmmaker and he's he's he's
evolved oh yes yes
but i i don't think he is much different
but
he was he
he was able to solidify a reputation
um and i believe it was 1978.
um that
the taxi driver came over this is 76 76
or 78. i think it was 76. seems like he
was earlier yeah sometimes
i'm not sure though
but yeah
um and so
it was he was able to settle a
reputation then
um
and he could he could go on
and and and continue to make personal
uh movies like that i mean the same
thing can
can be said for a lot of
people in that enchilada you know um the
same thing can be said for for spike lee
you know um but even so you know spike
lee has to fight
to get
financing
because he's
making movies that are about
messages
he's got he's trying to tell
he's got a message behind his story
you know
um
i remember years ago when he was still
alive um
i was i was
watching a panel on on robert altman
and
and he said robert altman said you know
it's like
someone asked him like in the panel like
how do you get financing for your film
and he's like
i don't know i
i find it just i i find it just as hard
to get financing as i think
any young filmmaker would this was like
um around 2000
he said this and
i
and i tended to believe him you know um
you know you you're you're you're you're
an older man
you know who's trying to go out there
and get financing to make a movie that
says something
and people aren't looking
to to do that and today
you know you we know what kind of movies
get made
you know
it's like
yeah they're not they don't want it
you know and it's understandable
it's a it's a business that you know
it's a it's it's it's it's a business
they're looking for a return
and that's the other thing that i think
that um writers should be very aware of
that
what they are in is a business now you
can consider yourself an artist and
that's absolutely fine i'm in fact i'm a
proponent for that i consider myself an
artist
be an artist
you know if that's what you want to be
be an artist but don't get mad
if you realize you're in a business
because that's what it is
you know it's that they're out there to
make money they're not out there to make
art you're out there to make art they're
out there to make money
you know
so yeah
do you feel like that's the real um test
of how long you want to stay in this
business or attempt to stay in it is to
realize that
well i mean
i think you're you you know you realize
what you do
as a writer you know you um you
understand where your lane is so to
speak and that's not to say that you
limit yourself to
to a track it's to say that
you are content um and you you you're
nourishing
um your creativity and and wherever it
is that you track
um for like example for myself um
i write i write screenplays and i also
write plays
you know and i enjoy writing plays a
great deal i enjoy this theater i enjoy
that experience you know i enjoy working
with actors in the terms of stage um
[Music]
but
and and and and
and and working and and staging the work
and and
and
and and and seeing it come alive
in a room full of people
where it's not um projected on a screen
it's a whole other experience
but you know this is the thing you know
this is all under the o of oh this is
what i do as a writer it's not under the
over what i do as a screenwriter
um so
i
at any one point or time you know i can
take my frustrations
to
writing a play
and
go down the street
get some friends together go into a
theater and say hey let's hear this
let's hear this out loud
[Laughter]
you know
so i mean
that's that's my feeling on it and and
and there's plenty of other writers that
that that do the same thing you know
we've got we've got um
writers that that cross both fields
aaron sorkin tracy letts
david mamet suzy lori parks these are
all
playwrights and screenwriters
um
ask them what they do
aaron sorkin's never gonna say oh i'm a
scream the air circuit's gonna go i'm a
writer
i write that's what i do you know as sam
can be said for for other people that
cross
um
um very you know the other mediums of
writing stephen king stephen king's not
gonna say yeah i'm a
screenwriter
mckeen's like i'm a writer
stephen king's bigger
than
than any one movie
so yeah